every time I start a new scene I'm
nervous and when that verge is on panic
I I get great ideas I try very hard to
get into USC film school and I just
didn't have the grades get in and I
realized this was going to be what I was
gonna do where I was gonna die trying
when I got into the group of the movie
brats it was the first time I felt like
an insider get the camera range write
the word around town was jaws was folly
and that I was gonna be a disaster
don don don dun-dun-dun the night just
opened when we look in going down all
the lines I said this is it there were
people that hated him people that blamed
him for ruining the movies all my films
come from the part of myself that I
really can't articulate schebler
changed my entire approach to cinema he
was like someone whose skin had been
torn off he has a dynamic sense of real
filmmaking you think about young kid one
day sneaking his way into a studio and
manifesting his own destiny it's a
pretty fantastic Hollywood story
you
you